Macaulay Culkin the ten-year-old star of
home alone couldn't be with us tonight
whoever he is watching the show this
evening with his new girlfriend
cher ladies and gentlemen it's just a
joke what was that good job our next
presenter was a nominee tonight for a
performance in The Grifters and she can
currently be seen in guilty by suspicion
and she'll be coming soon as none other
than Catwoman and Batman - why the
making - one didn't make money please
welcome a great actress Annette Bening
every costume designer begins with a
sketch pad and a concept adds historical
accuracy and hopefully emerges with a
look and feel that adds immeasurably to
a film this year's costume designs cover
styles and periods from garments worn by
first-generation Americans in Avalon
designed by Gloria Gresham the elegant
frou-frou and comp of Paris during the
time of Cyrano designed by Frank Oh
squirty know the frontier simplicity of
Dances with Wolves designed by Elsa's
and Pirelli the comic strip brought to
cinematic life in Dick Tracy designed by
milena Canon arrow
and the costumes that evoke the ancient
royal court of Denmark in Hamlet
designed by Mauricio Milano T
for costume design this year the Oscar
goes to franca Squar cioppino
for Cyrano de Bergerac
I am moved
thank you merci example rap no mercy lay
through death
merci et oh mercy